[Music]
after the first few hours of Mass Effect
Andromeda I was discouraged maybe even a
little distraught within that short span
of time I'd already encountered
unconvincing animations bog-standard
missions clunky user interface stilted
dialogue basically every red flag you
hope to avoid when approaching a lengthy
shooter RPG powered equally by action
and story thankfully Andromeda did
improve as I progressed I unlocked
exhilarating new combat options met
characters with deeper appeal than my
initial crew and discovered freely
explorable worlds that finally fulfilled
the series decade olds planet-hopping
promise and yet some of those early
problems persisted throughout and while
I did catch glimmers of Mass Effect's
greatness that shine was often dulled by
lifeless dialogue tedious missions and
even technical shortcomings we thought
it fought find them a new life that is
called damn trillion to its credit
Andromeda boldly abandons the familiar
much like its characters in place of the
iconic Commander Shepard we have writer
the daughter or son of a man chosen to
lead one of four arcs filled with
intergalactic explorers looking to found
colonies in a distant star cluster
several disasters later Reiter inherits
her dad's job and while the moments
leading to and including that scene are
pretty hackneyed the stakes really sink
in once you've reached the Nexus
Andromeda's version of the earlier games
Citadel here you discover the other
three arcs have gone missing and that
the Nexus which arrived ahead of the arc
has suffered every setback imaginable
from growing food shortages to a
veritable Civil War when leadership in
shambles the sudden arrival of an arc
immediately lands rider in an
uncomfortable position of power in
practice the scenario felt more
believable than typical you are the
chosen one cliches I understood why
those characters would look to me and
felt the weight of their desperation so
when the Nexus gradually sprang to life
as I started fixing problems I felt
genuinely accomplished an hour ago that
was all dark both the power from Eurasia
you're keeping the lights on you have my
vote in parallel with this more broadly
focused narrative which encompasses much
of the side contents the central
storyline revolves around an evil alien
race and it's delusional narcissistic
leader who opposes more of an immediate
threat than food shortages he is less
one-dimensional than he initially seems
but the plot is largely predictable in a
mindless blockbuster sort of way the two
stories intersect occasionally and both
pay off in the end
truthfully Andromeda story problems stem
more from delivery than from plot the
vast majority of in dramatist characters
are just dole your opinions more
important what do you think of your
people and conversations rarely delve
deeper than arduous get to know you
small talk no one yells or cries or
expresses any measurable emotion at any
point even romance options feel stilted
there's something unique about you
uneasy cruel but somehow profound we're
still your agency in these conversations
is limited
sure you can periodically select from up
to four dialogue options but these
frequently boil down to be optimistic or
be realistic not a huge difference and
regardless of what you pick your inputs
only rarely impact the outcome I can
only recall one major decision that had
serious repercussions and even that felt
contrived they'd also paled in
comparison to be memorably gut-wrenching
choices forced on me in the original
games what do you think military
outposts are scientific in fairness
Andromeda did sometimes surprised me
with poignant moments like my crew
comforting me in a dark hour and a
conversation with my partner AI about
the meaning of life
the game just buries these gems under
hours of empty or even cringe-worthy
interactions we discovered the remnant
and breach their vault and didn't get
killed overcame radiation poisoning a
number of times and didn't die
confronted by Kat at every turn once
again did not get killed thankfully I
didn't have to dig as deep to find the
things Andromeda does well it's worlds
for example are breathtaking to behold
and exciting to explore you eventually
uncover four mini open worlds as well as
smaller standalone areas like an
overgrown jungle outpost and your own
ships The Tempest the four major maps
are sizeable and offer drastically
different environments and hazards
they're also filled with NPCs chat up
and side missions to undertake you could
end up solving murders in a pirate port
setting at a Krogan fighting pits or
unlocking secrets in ancient yet
hyper-advanced vaults or you could just
wheel around in your nomad the galaxy is
vast and varied and that's worth being
excited about I also fell in love with
the combat especially later in the game
the core shooting mechanics feels
stronger here than anywhere else in the
series and the flexibility of the
progression system let me cherry pick
cool towers rather than locking me in to
a set character class I ended up
building well a space ninja basically I
could use tech to cloak myself biotics
to charge my enemies the shield buffing
sword to heal damage and the standard
jump Jets to dart away again the results
were consistently frantic and fun though
there are plenty of other options as
well
I enjoy basically everything I
experimented with even if most enemies
proved to be predictable adversaries
combats one major flaw is the crafting
system I would call it more of a missed
opportunity than a problem but crafting
is often the only way to get the weapons
and armor you actually want which means
hours of scanning objects to occur
research points and many headaches
dealing with the messy UI good luck
trying to directly compare weapon stats
the crafting and loadout stations are
also at opposite ends of your ship which
frequently forced me to run back and
forth to get things done I felt deeply
satisfied when I finally completed my
perfect loadout
I'm not sure it was worth the energy
crafting isn't Andromeda's biggest time
waster though that would be it's tedious
mission far too many open world quests
even some that feel important or come
packaged in an interesting premise
devolve into multi-step go here hit a
button errands there's always another
nap point somewhere across the map or an
NPC who needs exactly three items or a
crucial data pad that's unexpectedly
missing when you arrive these missions
desperately needed some editing or at
least a wider variety of gameplay
scenarios if you can collect the
necessary resources from Aradia
it should work the campaign and crew
loyalty missions provides better crafted
experiences but there's no avoiding at
least some of the unimaginative tedium
there is plenty to do outside of
missions however Andromeda includes a
somewhat convoluted meta game that
challenges you to raise planet's
viability levels by establishing
outposts and completing other quests you
can also hunt for memory triggers left
by your father that eventually reveal a
few interesting secrets and then there's
mining collectibles space travel strike
teams there's even a decent cooperative
multiplayer horde mode individually
these elements don't add much but
collectively they do round out the
sci-fi fantasy
unfortunately there's a dark cloud
hanging over all of this technical
issues yes the facial animations really
don't look great but the problems run
deeper on ps4 the framerate was all over
the place both in and out of combat on
both ps4 and PC I encountered several
audio issues most notably multiple lines
of dialogue playing at the same time
covering each other
I also saw several random glitches like
characters that fail to load during
conversations and enemies that fell into
the level geometry none of these issues
rendered the game unplayable but they
were noticeable and pervasive in many
ways Andromeda feels like a vision half
fulfilled it contains a dizzying amount
of content but the quality fluctuates
wildly its worlds in combat shine but
it's writing and missions falter as a
Mass Effect game Andromeda falls well
short of the nuance politics morality
and storytelling of its predecessor yet
even after 65 hours I still plan on
completing a few more quests the game
can't fully escape its shortcomings but
patient explorers can still find a few
stars shining in the darkness but today
whatever our reason
we take the first step toward a new
future for Humanity
today we begin to make our tree yeah
[Music]
you